casser la routine à l'eau
ça va très bien aller devant de
personnes
pimentez d'imprévus leur match je
m'associe prends mon fric il se fait
torturer à mort et maintenant il faut
attendre rêve qu'il ait envie de stopper
c'est ce qu'ils font tous oui ajoutez du
suspense le ghana aurait une police
criminelle manuel je suis sur le lieu de
découverte d'accord dit nous les
rebelles se cache
mélanger les genres aucune créature du
futur mais voulaient nous tuer s'ils
veulent entrer c'est pas un mur qui va
les arrêter le danger il est là mon dieu
laissez monter la température
mais là je pense que mme hanane alors il
faut que j'attende que ça refroidisse
savourer oui
luz il y en a plus on en veut et
d'épisodes en épisodes le meilleur est
toujours à venir
fait chier je vais rien moi toutes vos
envies sont sur canal+ série pourquoi se
priver qu'est ce qu'on s'amuse vieux
puits